so this is a sample of iridium now this
is a sponge type iridium so it's very
very finely divided very very
lightweight so we open the vial iridium
is at the bottom of the group that has
cobalt and radium and iridium like
radium can be used in a lot of catalysts
and here we have the glass ampule inside
and we can see here that the iridium
sample is a sponge now again you can see
that this is a very very very light
material and you can see it flowing
inside the vial in fact Iridium catalyst
sometimes will work much better than the
radium catalyst and there is a good
example where people have replaced the
iridium that replaced rhodium with
iridium and found that they can make
much more compound in the same chemical
plant and this is really good because
then you get more stuff coming out
without having to have any more metal
work chemical engineers have a very nice
name for this it's called D
bottlenecking
when you get more for the same amount of
plant